[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité une inflation qui
grimpe et des budgets serrés à un
contexte qui pousse de plus en plus de
français à revendre leurs effets
personnels pour gagner en pouvoir
d'achat quelques euros pour faciliter le
quotidien nous expliquera TV7 la chaîne
du groupe sud-ouest dans quelques
instants
des tirs à balles réelles et des
conditions extrêmes la rédaction de 8
Mont-Blanc dans ce journal nous conduira
dans les coulisses impressionnantes d'un
exercice militaire organisé il y a
quelques jours dans les Alpes et puis de
la musique légendaire et un voilier TBO
la chaîne du groupe Le Télégramme nous
dévoilera l'histoire d'un bateau qui fut
la propriété d'un des fondateurs des
Pink Floyd un voilier actuellement en
pleine préparation pour une course de
six mois en mer et puis en fin d'édition
nous vous conduirons en Martinique à la
découverte du dôme un espace entièrement
consacré à la découverte de la montagne
Pelée et de sa riche biodiversité un
sujet devient ATV pour terminer ce
journal
je vous le disais en une dans les titres
c'est une pratique désormais courante
dans la vie des Français revendre ses
effets personnels alors que l'inflation
continue de gagner du terrain certains
décident pour la première fois de se
tourner vers cette économie circulaire
des livres à l'électroménager en passant
par les bijoux quasiment tout se revend
les sommes glanées permettent de
soulager un portefeuille souvent malmené
exemple à Bordeaux avec ce reportage
divan branchi pour TV7 la chaîne du
groupe sud-ouest
c'est ce que j'allais vous poser comme
question c'est la première fois que vous
venez chez nous c'est une grande
première pour cette cliente dans ses
mains un ordinateur portable quasiment
neuf qui appartient à son gendre et
qu'elle s'apprête à vendre besoin
d'argent parce que c'est très très dur
pour tout le monde et aussi bien pour
nous voilà
j'espère
acheter il y a pas longtemps du coup moi
80 euros à peu près après quelques
minutes et un examen approfondi du PC ça
reproduit sur lequel je peux vous
proposer 90 euros
voilà une simple signature et la somme
est remise immédiatement en espèce
franchement je suis trop du moins pour
ma fille André informatique jeux vidéo
téléphonie aujourd'hui tout s'achète et
tout se revend alors en pleine période
d'inflation le directeur de ce magasin
constate que certains clients n'hésitent
plus à se séparer de leurs objets
personnels clairement ils peuvent pas
ils peuvent pas boucler leur moi
ou parce que ils ont une galère avec
leur boulot ou que il doit mettre de
l'essence tout simplement des produits
délaissés mais aussi des objets précieux
on peut avoir souvent des alliances à 35
euros de net le gramme le cours de l'or
atteint des records historiques dans
cette boutique installée en pleine
galerie marchande on rachète le métal
jaune sous toutes ses formes des bijoux
de famille transmis de générations en
génération et dont certains doivent se
séparer faute de moyens une partie de
notre clientèle qui vient parce que ils
ont un coup dur à passer et qui
revendent leur ordre qui est vraiment
une solution de financement une
clientèle qui n'hésite plus à revendre
pour gagner en pouvoir d'achat entre
février 202 et février 2023 les prix à
la consommation ont progressé de 6,3%
. une situation économique délicate pour
de nombreux Français qui s'inscrivent
vous le savez ces dernières semaines
dans un contexte tendu pour le système
bancaire après les États-Unis et la
Suisse des faillites sont-elles la
craindre en France notamment non estime
Steve gentily le président de la Banque
Internationale du commerce la BRED il
juge les banques hexagonales et
européennes sur son avis au micro de
Christophe frigo écoutez ce n'est qu'une
inquiétude le système bancaire français
est solide le système bancaire européen
est solide face à la compétition
mondiale nous avons de grands atouts
dans l'industrie bancaire bien sûr non
non et on le voit bien les crises la
première crise celle qui est arrivée il
y a une quinzaine d'années était une
crise américaine ce sont les Américains
qui nous ont vendus à travers les
suprêmes une crise et aujourd'hui
regardez aucune de nos banques n'étant
défaut
Christian Estrosi le maire de Nice était
l'invité de l'émission Face au
territoire jeudi matin sur TV5 Monde le
numéro 2 du parti horizon et notamment
revenu sur la situation sociale du pays
après une dixième journée de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites
pendant 15 ans les choses ont évolué
plutôt en mal en tout cas c'est la
perception qu'on en a dès qu'on voit ces
manifestations fleurir elles ont
l'autorité de l'État elle était aussi
de votre côté de votre bord politique
enfin d'abord je vous rappelle que nous
avons veillé à ce que cette violence se
traduise jamais dans les proportions où
elle se traduit aujourd'hui
je n'ai pas le souvenir de voir l'image
de grandes villes de France
ce n'est pas le cas de la mienne
d'ailleurs on voit s'entasser l'état de
poubelle qui servent ensuite à servir
l'instrument pour les brûler pour
incendier pour que ça se propage sur des
véhicules
c'est du jamais vu
nous avons eu la période des gilets
jaunes qui était d'une extrême violence
voilà face au territoire avec Christian
Estrosi comme invité et avoir ou à
revoir en replay sur le site internet de
TV5 Monde et sur aussi des partenaires
de l'émission Ouest-France Nice-Matin
france-anti 20 minutes la montagne et le
magazine Le Point
elles étaient plus de 200 000 en France
en 2021 les victimes des violences
conjugales sont devenues le triste
symbole d'une parole qui se libère
depuis le mouvement MiTo et pour
protéger ces personnes en grande
majorité des femmes des initiatives
simples mais efficaces sont de plus en
plus déployés par les collectivités dans
l'Oise vous allez le voir une petite
commune vient de créer des zones neutres
des espaces sécurisés et surveillés par
des caméras pour procéder dans
l'apaisement à l'échange d'enfants dans
le cadre d'une garde alternée les
précisions avec ce reportage de Jérémy
houblon pour oui au TV la chaîne de la
Voix du Nord
c'est un aménagement qui fait office de
petite révolution dans les
Hauts-de-France derrière ces deux places
de parking se cachent un enjeu majeur
celui des violents intra familiales on a
deux places de parking réservées
lorsqu'il s'agit notamment le vendredi
soir
d'échanger les enfants dans le cadre de
garde alternée à deux pas de la
gendarmerie est placé sous vidéo
surveillance les zones neutres
permettent de remettre de l'apaisement
dans des situations parfois sources de
tension malheureusement la ville n'est
pas épargnée parce qu'on appelle les
violences intrafamidales et n'a
malheureusement pas été rare que la
gendarmerie nationale ou que la police
municipale intervienne notamment à la
sortie des des classes un espace ouvert
et sécurisé destiné au couple séparés ou
en instance de divorce une première dans
la région salut Stéphane ça va le
résultat d'une collaboration entre
commune gendarmerie et police municipale
mobilisés pour répondre aux différents
besoins des familles ça peut être
également des gens des parents qui sont
vraiment bons termes et qui doivent
s'échanger les enfants avec des longues
distances ça peut être également des
couples séparés qui doivent quand même
se rencontrer pour des échanges
d'affaires entre eux et plutôt que de se
donner rendez-vous sur une zone
commerciale où ils ont des difficultés à
se rencontrer pourquoi pas se stationner
devant la brigade de gendarmerie de
façon sécurisée avec une grande facilité
pour se retrouver ou des aménagements et
de l'équipement de vidéo surveillance
10.500 euros financés par la
municipalité de Pont-Sainte-Maxence dans
quelques mois un bilan sera établi en
vue de dupliquer ces zones neutres sur
le département de l'Oise
sécurité encore dans ce journal avec
cette fois-ci un tout autre décor et
contexte un exercice militaire grandeur
nature de plusieurs jours dans les
montagnes savoyardes pour l'occasion 300
militaires étaient engagé dans des
conditions extrêmes et pour le moins
froides comme a pu le constater Emmanuel
JO pour la chaîne 8 Mont-Blanc regarde
aux alentours du refuge du rutord la
scène ne laisse que peu de place au
doute nous sommes sur un théâtre de
guerre depuis le début de la semaine
plusieurs sections se succèdent pour
harceler l'opposant et tenter de
conquérir sa position si la situation
comme les munitions utilisées sont tout
ce qu'il y a de plus réel aucun mort ne
sera à déplorer car dans les deux camps
se battent des chasseurs alpins issus
pour la plupart des septième et 13e BCA
un exercice grandeur nature qui met à
rue des preuves les hommes et le
matériel le plus dur je dirais que c'est
de tenir dans la durée en fait de pas
c'est facile d'être mouillé et de
rentrer le soir à la maison mais le plus
dur c'est d'être mouillé et de tenir
encore trois jours d'exercices derrière
à l'instar de l'exercice cers sur les
hauteurs de valoir quartz permet
d'acquérir de nombreux chasseurs aux
particularités du combat en montagne le
froid et la fatigue renforcée par un
rythme soutenu sur plusieurs jours est
en effet une stratégie d'entraînement
qui joue un rôle considérable dans
l'expertise militaire française
c'est des exercices de synthèse et en
fait les unités sont chargées de se
préparer pour ces exercices donc on
n'est pas ici dans l'apprentissage on
est dans la restitution et comme vous le
soulignez la restitution en combinant
toutes les fonctions opérationnelles
tous les métiers de la brigade de
montagne de façon à ce que sur le
terrain et donc dans des conditions
parfaitement réalistes d'un terrain
ouvert en montagne on est la combinaison
de ces compétences un entraînement qui
permet aux troupes de montagnes de se
prévaloir d'une image et d'une
expérience de premier ordre à l'heure ou
près d'un tiers de la 27e BIM est
actuellement déployée sur des théâtres
d'opérations extérieures à travers le
monde
voilà et du courage des forces armées à
celui des civils intéressons-nous à
présent à une tendance en plein
développement les stages de survie
comment s'orienter s'alimenter ou encore
allumer un feu en plein de forêt voilà
des notions qui peuvent s'avérer utile
en cas d'imprévu solitaire un reportage
près de Rennes de Natacha Astor pour la
chaîne TVR regardez
je vais vous perdre dans la forêt
couteau à la taille gourde dans le sac
au petit Fougeret on apprend des
techniques pour survivre dans la nature
le soleil commence à se coucher il y a
plus beaucoup d'eau dans la gourde vous
voyez bien que là c'est pas le chemin
que vous aviez pris tout à l'heure vous
reconnaissez rien et vous dites je veux
retourner au parking où je me suis garé
ce matin même s'il y a 8 10 km là sans
être des des fous là je reconnais des
traces de vélo Renan et moniteur de
survie il donne des stages d'un à trois
jours avec l'école buissonnière qu'il a
fondé la SCOL Loire
ils savent se faire un feu ils
comprennent que l'eau il y a des enjeux
derrière qu'il faut pas la prendre
n'importe comment n'importe quand et
avec ça on arrive déjà à prolonger leur
vie sur deux trois quatre jours assez
facilement la survie peut découler d'une
mauvaise organisation ou d'une blessure
pendant une randonnée un trek un périple
en VTT ou en canoë si on a perdu en
rando une journée seule comment pouvoir
s'orienter s'alimenter survivre après
avoir ramassé du bois les aventuriers
d'un jour apprennent à manier la pierre
à feu
[Musique]
restons en Bretagne dans cette édition
pour découvrir je vous le disais dans
les titres l'histoire étonnante d'un
voilier everika c'est son nom prendre à
la mer en septembre prochain pour une
course de plusieurs mois un événement
pour lequel son équipage se prépare sur
fond de musique en effet everyka a
appartenu écouter bien à une légende de
la musique la des fondateurs des Pink
Floyd explication de Caroline chevrolier
pour TBO la chaîne du groupe telegram
hazard ou destin Dominique Dubois croise
pour la première fois evrika en 2008 sur
les pontons du port d'Antigua dans les
Caraïbes
Erika était à côté de mon bateau en
discutait avec le skipper et on a fait
une visite croisée des bateaux donc j'ai
découvert ce bateau avec sous la
couchette tribord du carré le piano pour
le pianiste des Pink Floyd derrière dans
le cabinariat il y avait le disque d'or
c'était absolument incroyable ce bateau
a appartenu pendant 25 ans à Chris white
aujourd'hui des CD de cette époque
subsiste encore quelques traces
il a écrit un morceau qui s'appelle
everyka et si Dominique Dubois en a fait
l'acquisition c'est pour remplacer le
futuro en janvier dernier le Swan 6501
et victime de la tempête Gérard le
compte à rebours est lancé l'objectif
pour l'ancien dirigeant de multiplace
chantier de construction de bateaux de
course au large et l'Océane globe race
qui part en septembre prochain depuis 14
ans je pense à cette course le suivait
ça de près dans toutes les revues de
voile qui existaient penvicis c'était
juste bateau extraordinaire c'était
juste magique c'est l'Everest de de
toutes les ancien le plaisancier
compétiteur embarque famille et amis
dans cette course à la voile autour du
monde de 8 mois 25 personnes vont se
relayer tout au long du parcours pour
l'heure un convoyage de 380 000 entre
l'Angleterre et Lorient a déjà permis de
prendre en main les Vika en hiver donc
avec des conditions hivernales qui nous
ont permis de valider le fait que ce
bateau est vraiment fait pour la
navigation au grand large avant de
rejoindre La Trinité-sur-Mer son port
d'attache deux semaines de travaux vont
être effectués sur le bateau le coup de
cette Rolls-Royce des mers comme le
qualifie son nouveau propriétaire reste
quant à lui confidentiel
voilà connaissez-vous les carpes Koïs
ces poissons de bassin très appréciés en
Asie sont également très prisés en
France pour leur couleur et leur taille
dans la Loire un jeune homme en a fait
son activité et revanche ses poissons
apporter du Japon 200 à plus de 1000
euros pour certains vous allez le voir
c'est l'inertie il y a est allé à sa
rencontre pour TL7 la chaîne de la Loire
dans ce hangar Luka rock garde une
centaine de cartes koï tout arrive
directement du Japon le jeune
entrepreneur a fait le voyage en octobre
dernier pour les choisir lui-même chez
les producteurs et déjà certains clients
ont fait leur précommande pour vendre
les poissons déjà sur internet
directement sur Facebook on prend chaque
bol de poisson en photo pour pour en
vendre un maximum déjà depuis le Japon
Lucas Rogue s'adresse aux connaisseurs
et passionnés comme lui il faut dire que
la carpe koï japonaise n'est pas un
poisson rouge certains spécimens ont une
valeur à 5 chiffres ici les prix vont de
100 à 1 millier d'euros c'est un
investissement et pour cet acheteur un
cadeau spécial pour ses 40 ans
moi je trouve ça magnifique et très
apaisant donc j'ai plaisir le soir à
rentrer du travail et m'occuper de ces
beaux poissons et ça fait partie aussi
d'une décoration de jardin on va dire
aussi avec tous les bassins les massifs
fleuro à côté des variétés sont pas
heureuses du tout tout ce qui est
Karachi
elles viennent elles nous touche les
doigts en plus de ces Carpes Lucas rock
propose de créer des bassins chez les
particuliers et le marché se développe
mais attention il faut bien réfléchir
avant de se lancer ces poissons peuvent
vivre entre 30 et 60 ans chez nous au
Japon certains ont atteint les 200 ans
voilà si les enfants se rendent à
l'école en oui cycle dans les rôles une
petite commune et la première
collectivité à cette équipe de ce mode
de transport scolaire pour le moins
original un vélo navette qui permet de
transporter jusqu'à 9 enfants en même
temps une solution pratique rassurante
et écologique pour le trajet domicile
école mais la nicare on pourvie
Occitanie
salut contrairement à ce que l'on
pourrait croire ceci n'est pas une
balade mais un ramassage scolaire tous
les jours mais d'ici Yonne une partie de
la ville pour transporter les enfants à
l'école une idée un peu folle qui s'est
concrétisée en janvier dernier moi
j'étais animateur périscolaire j'étais
également au passage piéton
et j'ai vu une maman elle galérait le
grand poulailler à leur vélo le deuxième
il boudait et le troisième il allait au
Pilat et je me suis c'est pas possible
on a plein de fratries et comment on
peut faire et ben là on a les CP CE1 CE2
sur le wifi et les CM1 CM2 en vélo
derrière l'association en charge du
projet croule sous les demandes 27
familles sont déjà inscrites pour
participer ici tout le monde est conquis
par ce nouveau transport écolo je suis
rassuré parce que du coup je sais qu'ils
sont arrivés à bon port et du coup j'ai
plus ce problème de monter des cendres
et courir surtout
Mehdi klaxon ben c'est bien et en plus
de voir en plus ça évite de marcher en
Occitanie ce vélo électrique équipé de
panneaux solaires a été financée par la
municipalité un investissement de près
de 10000 euros les villes aux alentours
de Montpellier le matin entre 8h et 8h30
sont vraiment saturés de voiture donc la
priorité principale c'est des engorger
un petit peu le centre du village un
second vélo est déjà en cours de
construction pour une mise en service en
allez prenons la direction de nos
jardins dans ce journal pour partir à la
récolte écoutez bien de la sève de
bouleau breuvage printanier auquel on
octroie des vertus pour la santé une
affirmation qui a voulu vérifier la
rédaction de vos TV au cœur d'un espace
vert où l'on récolte jusqu'à 200 litres
de cet élections un sujet dan Didier et
de Denis Lequin regarde
ce qui met la pompe en route c'est quand
il fait frais la nuit et un peu plus
chaud la journée donc à froid chaud
froid chaud hop ça met la scène en route
ce jardinier repère aussi le phénomène
de sève montante au champ de la grive
draine qui annonce le retour des beaux
jours ici à berchies-granges la récolte
de sève c'est la première activité de
l'année chaque jour Thierry passe auprès
des 800 boulots de la propriété pour
vérifier les installations
pour respecter l'arbre c'est à ne pas
faire des trous trop profonds ne pas en
faire 36 sur le même arbre forcément et
autrement ça ça se passe tout seul on
perce l'arbre et après on repasse tous
les 24 heures tous les matins pour
récolter la sève que l'arbre à donner
jusqu'à 5 litres sur les 200 produits
chaque jour sont récupérés au pied de
l'arbre un terrain éloigné de la
pollution propice à cette activité ici
on est sur une moraine glaciaire donc la
sève un par conséquent c'est très riche
en sels minéraux on est sur du granit ce
qui est pas le cas de boulot qui pousse
dans les plaines ou dans des sols trop
argiles ce qu'il y a d'autres arbres qui
auraient les mêmes vertus alors non pas
particulièrement agréable à boire
surtout c'est ça en fait les boulots
faut savoir que c'est les moines
défricheurs qui ont découvert ça vous
pouvez le boire c'était légèrement sucré
et ils sont aperçus mais qu'ils avaient
tout simplement de l'énergie pour
continuer leur travail la sève est
souvent assimilée à un élixir de
printemps aux autres contre-indications
de multiples vertus qui se feraient
ressentir après deux semaines de
consommation quotidienne il y a plein de
lego-éléments qu'on peut qui sont
directement assimilables par la sève
c'est vraiment ça passe vraiment
directement dans votre organisme vendu
sur place la poche hermétique coûte 33
euros ici de quoi faire ladite cure à
conserver à moins 4 degrés et à l'abri
de la lumière pour éviter la
fermentation à l'origine du goût acide
en cas de mauvais stockage un breuvage
saisonnier dont la récolte s'arrête à
l'arrivée des premiers bourgeons mais
qu'on peut consommer toute l'année à
condition qu'il soit passé dans des
cuves de lacto-fermentation le liquide
se charge alors en probiotique
après 40 ans de bons éloyaux services
les propriétaires de la brasserie chez
Nini s'apprête à baisser le rideau leur
restauration simple et authentique a
fait quatre décennies durant le bonheur
de leurs clients devenu des amis Canal
32 s'est glissé dans la cuisine de cet
institution si représentative des
traditions culinaires de nos terroirs
regardez
dès que l'on franchit le pas de porte de
l'institution gastronomique Romillonne
chez Nini 40 ans est donné ici les
clients sont formels que du fait maison
c'est une tuerie
le chef et sa conjointe collaboratrice
défendent la tradition culinaire
française et des plages généreux rôti de
porc des frites j'ai la langue la langue
de bœuf du coq au vin ça faire du coq au
vin je fais des tomates farcies je suis
pas marqué je suis pas tenté par les
pizzas et tout ça ça tombe bien leurs
clients non plus si à l'ouverture les
ouvriers venaient régulièrement
aujourd'hui ce sont plutôt des retraités
et quelques actifs pour les services on
fait bar restaurant des pots de pain
pâtisseries et traiteur nous clients
arrivent à se connaître à force tous les
dimanches de pluie à 17h on peut être
encore là c'est nos clients c'est aussi
nos amis chez Nini va baisser le rideau
le mois prochain le couple a réussi à
revendre le restaurant et l'appartement
à l'étage une page de l'histoire
Romillonne se referme a fondé petit
restaurant là en 76 et puis Nice est à
ma mère il est parti en retraite et puis
j'ai racheté le restaurant quand on
habite à Romilly on connaît forcément le
restaurant Chez Nini d'ailleurs moi j'ai
eu été impressionné du nombre de partage
que j'ai pu avoir sur les réseaux
sociaux
Isabelle prévoit de s'inscrire pour la
première fois Pôle emploi en attendant
la retraite à 66 ans Laurent prévoit
quant à lui d'aller à la pêche ou aux
champignons pour cuisiner à l'occasion
des plats simples et bon
voilà et on leur souhaite bien
évidemment une belle retraite remplie de
plats généreuses et de partage une
exposition en plein air sur des panneaux
publicitaires l'idée originale nous
vient de Limoges où la culture s'invite
sur les écrans et où la publicité est
remplacée par des créations graphiques
un projet culturel qui trouve sa source
dans les confinements et qui se prolonge
aujourd'hui à l'aide de QR code image et
propos recueillies par Alain Druot sur
place
on peut plus de deux ans avec l'envie
juste après le confinement et au moment
du confinement d'apporter un peu de joie
aux habitants qui étaient enfermés chez
eux et qui n'avaient plus la possibilité
d'aller voir des expositions on prend
son petit téléphone on va sur
l'application intégrée sur le téléphone
ou sinon vous en charger une vous ouvrez
le lien
et vous avez l'image animée
de l'oeuvre du système cette thématique
c'est qu'il vienne pour amener du happy
feeling au sein de l'existence des gens
allez direction la Martinique pour
terminer ce journal et vous allez le
voir sur l'île aussi la culture s'ouvre
sur l'extérieur grâce au Dôme les
touristes peuvent désormais en savoir un
peu plus sur la montagne Pelée et son
environnement ce nouvel espace situé sur
le flanc du volcan a ouvert ses portes
il y a quelques mois et veut attirer les
curieux en quête de nature et de
connaissance visite guidée de Jean-Marc
dabreux pourvient à TV sur place
à 700 mètres du sommet de la montagne
Pelée un musée à ciel ouvert
ses deux touristes belges arrivent ici
un peu par hasard
une grande maison noire ou un bâtiment
noir on savait pas du tout ce qui allait
avoir l'occasion de parfaire leur
connaissance après avoir effectué
l'ascension de la montagne Pelée donc je
savais que l'éruption du volcan est en
1902 mais c'est vrai qu'après à part ça
exposition de roche magmatiques
explication sur la formation du volcan
c'est vraiment un espace qui est dédié à
ses études et à la composition de la
montagne Pelée la visite se veut aussi
immersive avec la prochaine ouverture de
chambre d'hôtes ce sont des hébergements
qu'on appelle semi troglodyte d'ici le
mois de juin on aura reçu tout le
mobilier le lit comme les commodes etc
mais c'est fait pour rester simple
l'objectif d'avoir une expérience
authentique et depuis votre chambre vous
pourrez voir les étoiles directement
depuis la couche parmi les guides Silvio
un jeune Martiniquais de retour au pays
depuis la crise covid en 2020
comptabilité et je me suis vite rendu
compte en voyageant en explorant le
monde et surtout en connectant à la
nature que ce que je voulais faire
c'était y participer la défendre et
surtout la faire connaître
on n'a pas encore appris à siffler pour
vous faire lire les oiseaux mais ça va
venir
si vous mettez là pendant un instant et
que vous restez justement à faire ce
bruit là je vous assure que les oiseaux
s'approchent aujourd'hui loin d'être un
incontournable dans le programme des
touristes le dôme souhaite attirer le
maximum de visiteurs la structure est
désormais ouverte aussi le week-end
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
merci de nous avoir suivis on se
retrouve très vite pour une prochaine
édition au revoir à tous
[Musique]